E: I'm gonna prove how good I am (sure)
T: I,M GONNA PROVE THAT MATH IS A SCIENCE
M
T: I mean, you're pretty good at making stuff up...
M: I've never made up a damn thing in these things, things.
E: I know the history of pretzels
M: You do? Alright, lay it on us.
E: Pretzels. What are they? Twirly, twirly birds that you grab with your hands and you wrap them around.
E: Where did they come from?
E: Where did they go?
E: Back in 1987, a young man named
E: walked into a kitchen and he said "Hey, I'd like to make myself a little bit of a snack!"
E: So he grabbed some flour.
E: He grabbed some yeast.
E: He grabbed some salt; maybe a little bit of pepper.
E: Then he went to work.
Pulled up his sleeves, and he-
[THWAP]
-washed his hands, as you always before cooking a great meal.
And he splashed them into a bowl,
mixing vigorously until... out of the oven came...
something brand new!
Something.. his eyes had never seen before.
Something that would take the 90's by storm.
The Pretzel had been made,
and today, that's what we're doing.
Mark: *sigh*
Ethan: We're taking JORDAN B PRIETZEN's original recipe
and we're honoring it and then serving it up to him in his memory.
[Kissing noise]
Amen.
Mark : A-Alright..
Mark: (Warbled) I-I didn't, I didn't really agree with the idea of letting Ethan do an intro.
I thought like I could give him a chance to really prove himself.
uh...
And he really let me down on that one.
Um, that was awful
I've never let anyone else do an intro for my channel before, ever,
and as the first video to ever be,
introduced by someone else, I feel like this just...
just like, really shat on the dream
of Markiplier Makes as a whole.
But you know, I'm not gonna let him know that
you know I always carry a smile on 'cause I'm always very much,
I'm about always smiling. That's my new initiative hashtag.
Always be smiling, #ABS, always be smiling, so.
I'm gonna take that, take that idea into the future so, anyway.
Tyler: (Warbled) Yeah, there's gonna be a lawsuit
against Mark for uh... trying to take my hashtag,
that's, that's pretty much all I need to say.
Mark: (Normal) The oven's preheated,
the water's boiling
So, we have all the ingredients we need to make a pretzel
We've got flour, we've got confectionery sugar,
we've got...
non-brand oil, we've got...
store-brand butter, we've got... store-brand butter.
Gold medal- [5 Slap Sound Effects]
So, we... combine these ingredients with yeast,
and then you..
[Woosh]
You... [More Woosh] fold it into a pretzel shape. Yeah?
Ethan: (Laughing)
Mark: If you guys know-
Ethan: Washing my hands as all good chefs do.
M: Alright, so there are a few complicated steps,
but as is usual with "Markiplier Makes",
we do not have a recipe.
We never have had a recipe. We don't need a re-
[Wheeze]
We don't NEED A RECIPE.
Because we are
Cooking
Innovators.
Not masters, we're explorators.
You think that Lewis and Clark were masters of exploring?
Explorators?
(Echoing) SHUT UP >:[
You think that Lewis and Clark were masters of exploration before they set out on the Oregon Trail?
Like they, didn't know what the hell they were doing.
They didn't know where the hell they were going
and yet they still found...
SOMETHING
The Louisian-
[Ethan laughs]
They found- YEAH, Louisiana Purchase-
M: THEY WERE EXPLORING THE NEW TERRITORY FOR THE LOUISIANA PUR-
THAT WAS THEM, WASN'T IT? That was them!
They were...it was!
And they found ALLLL of Louisiana!
They found it all! They found all of it...
Which back in the- don't start! OH MY GOD!!
You said that you were starting!
Alright, whatever, we're starting, okay.
Alright, so it's flour, water, salt,
butter, oil and a little bit of sugar, and the most important ingredient is yeast, which I don't think you add first.
I think you do because you have to let the yeast rise, right?
That's how that works.
...yeah!
Are you done?
Yeah.
Measuring is for PUSSIES
I AM A PENIS!
[Soft thud]
[Laughter]
Have either of you ever made pretzels before?
No, I've seen it though..
Mark: (Warbled) I lied. I've made pretzels so many times in my life.
I'm like a master. I'm gonna crush these guys in this competition.
I'ma crush 'em.
Ethan: (Warbled) Now I feel like I really started this whole pretzel thing because they didn't want to start that yet
and they were just blabbering on and I-I got ahead of 'em. I got ahead of them.
I put that yeast in, I put that flour in, that sugar, all of it,
and I'm ready to do Jordan B. Prietzen proud.
I've done a lot of...  praying in my private time...
to the pretzel gods, and Jordan B. Prietzen,
and I, you know, think I've got his spirit on my side.
(Normal) Do you not have any stuff?
(Normal) I provided you everything that you needed! Why do you-
Ex- ex- ex- fucking- scuse!
You said I have hands, you said that I have all the tools required.. What are you mixing with?
Ethan: Scissors. [Giggles]
All 3: [Laughter] And if it's not mixing well enough, you just cut it up!
You know... you right.
AH IT'S REALLY HOT!!!
[Agonized scream]
[More agonized screaming]
Where are the scissors?... Oh wait.
[Laughing] Ethan's mixing with them.
IT'S SO HOT!!
How do I open this withou-
[Continued agonized outcries]
[Whimper]
by your hands sissy~
[Another whimper, more defeated this time]
[Nervous laughter] Ethan, can you just gimme a snip?
Oh, [Single tiny laugh] of course.
There may be... a little bit of the stuff on there.
You didn't snip deep enough
Oh... just pour it. There we go.
Mark: Ah, it's fine!
Mine's not looking too bad.
I don't know what it's supposed to look like, but
MINE'S LOOKING BETTER THAN ETHAN'S.
Alright let me show you something my grandpappy taught me.
[Various thudding and thwapping noises]
HA! joke's on you. Never met my grandpa!
Now. [SLAP] I've got a nice- [SLAP] fine dough.
Amy: The audio on this. [Laughter] It's a little sloppy but here's something that others don't know...
[More thudding and slapping.]
[Amy gasps]
Forgot that you're here
[Mark & Tyler laughing]
I like how he's just over there whispering.
Thinks he knows something that we don't. I mean, I bet he knows a lot of things that we don't.
I mean that's-
M: Every person has individual subsets of knowledge
Well, I was talking more in regards to
baking and pretzels and dough.
I mean I know nothing.
If he even knows like, how they look
he probably knows more than I do.
I- i have at least have an idea of how they look.
Oh, just because you were brought up
rich enough to afford pretzels.
T: Whoa whoa whoa!
M: Unlike me, I had to put dirt into the form of a pretzel...
I was just guessing at it!
AND IT WAS DELICIOUS!
More flour..
That's too much flour.
Oh thanks. I actually uh..needed that, that's plenty though.
[Laughing] Okay cool.
[Nervously] Did we clean this table before I started working on it?
No.
Did we DIRTY this table before we started working on it?
Yeah-h-h..
[Concerned] What was that?
Did I wash my hands before I started?
EVERY GOOD COOK "WATCHES" HIS HANDS
I TOLD YOU THAT IN THE BEGINNING!
Wash, not watch.
-and listen!
Ohohoho! Watch your MOUTH, mister!
You didn't -- You didn't wash your hands-
Why are you still over there?
Why are you over-.. Minding your- business, bitch!?
All 3: [laughter]
[WOOSH]
[SLAP]
I think that helps, I've seen people do that
it really like gets the,
IT GETS THE YEAST GOIN'
They really like it.
T: They like the smack..?
Yeah, they're kinky little fuckers like that. UHN.
Yeah, what's my name?
How's the dough? How's your dough coming along? The view has been blocked.
[Smack]
Why are you laughing at me?
Nothing.
I'm- I'm really doing this and you're over there laughing..
I'm doing it!
What are you doing?!
I'm being patient!
It's not all about hard work sometimes..
...sometimes you just gotta know when to cool the jets a little bit.
I'll cool your jets...
: Can you pass me that, uh- oil there, Ethan?
Don't do it. It's a trick.
Put out your hand. Put out your hand.: No- no no.
[Quietly]
Oh, i'm sorry.
Alright...
[SMACK]
What- Goddamn you both of you!
No! You can't just say things are okay and then they're okay.
No!
[Tyler laughing]
You just say "hey it's alright!" , and then you go on your day..
No! [Breaks into laughter]
I didn't pay taxes in 2016, that's alright.
[Mark and Tyler laughing]
Fuck yeah! [SMACK]
[Relentless smacking and Mark mumbling]
Fuck yeah-
[Even more smacking]
You Close? You Close?!
YEAH YOU CLOSE?!
Yeah!
Alright I think it's good.
[Nervous laughter] I think you need some time alone.
[Giggling]
Is that what you do when you J.O.? (JACK OFF XD)
[All 3 laugh loudly]
Do you ask yourself..
(Intensely) You close??
T: Are you Close?!
[Mark laughing]
You close?
(Warbled) You see, it's conflicting because you have to let the yeast rise
We really don't have enough time to let the yeast rise properly.
Huh? We don't have enough time and that's..
[Sighing] That's the sad thing.
(Warbled) Alright so what they don't know is probably the proofing step.
That's gonna be the one item that they really fail on.
I know how to proof things. But what I don't know is how long to proof things.
Also, proofing is when you wait.
(Normal) Where's the saran wrap?
Find it?
Also, is there saran wrap?
Amy: To the left of the fridge.
No, don't give him help!
[Pitched-down frustrated grunt]
Do you need saran wrap?
No. T: Yes. M: No. Why? Why would you do that?
Cause I know how to proof.  You don't know how to proof!
I know how to proof.
Prove it!
Well how do you do it?
You let it sit in the fridge for a little bit.
[Tyler and Mark mumbling]
E: You see?
One step ahead
Yeah you know.
One step ahead of the game.
You definitely know.
I've already proofed EVERYTHING.
M: Man, that's some nice-looking dough, buddy.
*Realizes something again* Wait.....Wait.
M: We're missing an ingredient.
E: Eggs.
M: Egg. *Ethan laughs*
M: Egg.
M: EGG.
M: *urgently* E G G !
E: Do we have it?
M: Egg.
[Frantically] Don't touch my egg! DONT TOUCH MY EGG!
DONT TOUCH MY EGG!
M: Are you using this?
E: oh-
M:Okay good.
[Offscreen deliberate coughing]
E: That doesn't mean that you can use it
[More coughing]
That's my property...
[Offscreen deliberate coughing]
E: Don't give 'em any hints guys.
You think Jordan B. Prietzen would use an egg?
You... you...
Tyler: [Tiny gasp]
E: dishonorable..-
E: dont.. do it.. [Laughs]
E: not like that..
Amy: Not yet! Not yet!
Amy: Not yet.
[Very wet, squishy sound effects]
E: That's nice...
M: Yeah???
M: Thank yo-
T: (Warbled) I think they were actually all lacking was sugar.
I didn't see them use any sugar whatsoever within their... their recipe.
M: I used sugar!
T: And-
E: *quietly* I used sugar..
...Anyway, I think they forgot the sugar and they're lying to me.
I think I've got them beat. My dough looks fabulous. It's in the fridge.
It's proofing, it's gonna prove itself worthy of being eaten by the most
critical critiques of the pretzels.
Which is not Ethan's invented inventor of the pretzel.
M: I used sugar. Did you use sugar?(If you are wondering why the letter starting their names are here.. Well cause I got LAZY! XD)
E: Yes.
M: I used sugar.
M: You know what the eggs are for...?
T: I know what the eggs for. M: That's great
M: When--ok, my hand was here first, but-
[Laughter]
T: Y-you're encroaching on my third-
M: Dude--I own this table.
E: He's got a point.
M: You done yet?
E: When I say so--
M: What technique is this?
T: Are you making a volcano?
E: Yeah a lil bit
[Laughter]
E: You wanna stick your finger in there, see what's up?
M: [Loud inhale] Uh! You close? You close??
[Laughter]
E: Too hard, too hard..!
M: Sorry.
M: You close???
*more giggling*
T: No, you can go harder than THAT. *smacks slightly harder*
M: You close? You close? You close? *smacking him harder and harder*
T: O H
*giggles*
*SMACKS TABLE*
M: So we've proofed for an indeterminate amount of time we've decided that...
...it's proofed
so we're gonna pull them out of their "proofing locations."
In the middle of us not recording and not recording,
Tyler had a... epiphany. *giggles*
M: I'll let him, uh...
T: I didn't know what proofing was, so...
M: *gets angry again* You said!! You said,
"I know what proofing is,"
and I was like, "Oh yeah? Tell me!"
"In the fridge!" And I was like...
T: Listen, we did that for the pizza dough.
M: *sarcastically* Riight..
So the general gist is that it should double in size. Has yours doubled?
E: *pathetic chuckle* Uhh....
T: Actually mine's pretty close to doubled.
M: I don't think so..
T: I think so.
M: Now that,
THAT'S-, OH~ yeah that's doubled in size.
Ethan: OH?~
M: *mimicked Amy's request*
Ninja: THEFUCKYOUSAIDTOMEYOULIL'SHIT!
*Everyone Laughs*
M: sorry!!
MARKS A WOOS XD J.K I LUV EM
E: Amy's gonna come across that table...
M: I'm sorry! *Mark & Ethan laughing*
E: The look on your face, it just...
M: So, we need an oiled surface.
NOT a floured- do what you want
E: *laughs*
E: No, oil's- Oil me up.
M: UH!
T: Oh-
M: You want some?
E: Yeah, just a little...-  M: UH!
E: Awhh, yeah~
M: UNH! Alright-
M: You want more?
Yeah, you want more don't ya? Yeah you do. *laughs*
M: Anyway, so we roll them out and then we shape the pretzels.
M: See, mine doubled in size, mine's freaking huuuge!
*smack*
M: Mine's huuuuge!
M: Look at that.
E: Look at the size of that!
M: Look! Look at the shape. It's a very nice- 'Got a lil curve. That's okay.
E: That's just a little bit of a curve.
M: It's so nice. I think this is probably gonna be really close!
E: *laughing*
M: What?? *laughs*
E: I'm just thinking of like, someone seeing your dick...
E: for the first time
*laughter*
E: And you're just like, Look at this! It's really good!
E: Look at the SIZE of it! It's got a nice curve...
*more giggling*
E: Are we supposed to make multiple pretzels?
M: Yeah. Make like, two.
*clap sound as Mark tries the fancy twisting method*
Frustrated Mark: *sighs* okay...
*Mark finally gets it!*
T: I got a thicc boi. *small wheeze*
M: I've got a pretzel. I did it. I did it.
E: With one-?
M: I fucking did it. Oh, oh my god!
M: I got a pretzel!
M: Oh my god!
M: Oh my god!!!
M: *cackles maniacally*
M: ... Oh no...
E: *gasppp*
M: I'll never be able to recreate the magic..
E: *chuckles abit*
M: I recreated the magic!!
E: *chuckles*
M: We'll make three pretzels, each one incrementally bigger!
Alright, mine are ready to go in.
M: Okay. So the important thing is, when you have your boiling water, which is definitely boiling...
*doggo in background*...you want to-- What is in there..?
M: Okay, there's some particulates in there.
M: Alright, so you put baking soda in the water...
The recipes never say how much, it's always just, "some baking soda".
M: Okay, so this water is not boiling but I don't think that matters...
so... I'm just gonna pop her in.
M: I think it's supposed to float.
M: I also think it's supposed to be boiling.
E: You're drowning it.
T:You're just, uh, crisping the bottom a little bit..
M: No soggy bottoms here!
E and T (chorus): No soggy bottoms.
M: No soggy bottoms.
*All 3 laughs*
M: It's floating! It's floating!
M: It's floating! I don't know if that's good or bad
but I mean it's floating. So that's a sign...
I'mma guess that's good enough.
I'mma guess. And then BLAP, that's my first dumpin'.
M: OWWW!
E: Why did you touch it??
M: IT'S HOT!
E: Yeah!
E: Is that... Pot gonna be big enough for that?
M: *more weird voices*(???) look at this, and look at that!
E: *mimicked Marks weird sounds* Whoaw!
M: Look at this and look at that.
M: Is it really, what we're not gonna have enough is for all of them on this. So that's why I was like two per...
T: Yeah.
M: I won't cook this one.
That's looking okay. It's still not boiling. But okay, I'm gonna say this is good.
M: MAYBE.
Okay! Those are my two pretzels. This one lost his shape, but that's okay.
M: See, that, look at that boil! I should have waited...
M: I'm gonna boil this big one.
M: *impressed* That's a nice-looking pretzel, man.
E: That is a nice looking--
M: All right, go for it. Go go go.
E: Why do I need to do mine at the same time?
M: Cuz we're out of time.
M: Come on stuff it in!
E: No, it's gonna be ruined...
E: I'm, I'm gonna have a handicap...
M: ok fine...
Amy: The recipe says one at a time.
M: {This is what Ethan always does. He's not a team player. He doesn't work for the group}
M: {He never listens when, you know, time is of the essence and he's always taking his own time trying to make things perfect}
{Well, Ethan it's never going to BE
perfect because you're not perfect.}
*Notice Ethan's fogged glasses*
*Mark's POV ends*
E: He got big, (M: Wow) he got very big. Mark: *impressed again*
E: Is this mine?
T: Yep
M: Mine didn't puff I think because it wasn't boiling.
E: Alright. I feel good about mine. I think that that's the way--
M: Get out of the way.
E: You don't get to put- Oh.
M: Gonna need two hands for this one.
Here we go, I'm going for it. T: Whoa!
T: That's a big boi
E: That looks like soup.
T: It smells like a dumpling.
M: Yeah, well, you know
M: maybe..Maybe I accidentally made dumplings, what of it, fuck you!
M: Alright, so the oven's ready so we just pop them right in.
T: Nope!
M: We pop them right in
T: NO
M: That's fucking gross man..
T: Called egg wash
M: I know what it is.
M: Alright you don't even need a bowl to get your egg wash
Cuz you just, it comes with a bowl.
S'cuse me. Excuse me
T: I can move that closer for yo-
M: No, I don't need i- I don't need you.
M: Excuse me, excuse me! Excuse me!
*oOoOoOOOooooh*
Oh, oh gosh.
M: And I know the final step. I know it..
M: WATCH OUT
E: What are you doing?
M: You gonna cut it so it doesn't 'splode.
Snip snap
Snip snap snip snap
Okay, they're going in.
T: I feel like the big one should be the lower one..
M: I think you should shut up!
T: NO
M: Oh...
*giggling*
E: And now we wait. M: *punches Tyler's dough
M: *grabs Tyler's dough* That's what you get!
T: NO that's my--!
*his dough explodes*
E: Now we wait. M: Now we wait.
Alright
Amy: Should we start a timer? Start counting.
T: 1
M: 2
Everyone: 3
E: I got it
M,T: 10..
T: Eleven...
M: Okay, cut!
*SMACK*
M: It's been about, how long has it been?
T: 11 minutes
M: Been 11 minutes, this is what we looking at right now..
Oooh
Looks pretty good
E: Mine..are THICC
M: Wow *laughs*
T: Yours are real big!
M: Wow!
M: Alright, uh, the one up top is looking real fun!
E: Some of the bottom fell off
M: Don't worry
E: That looks like a pretty evenly baked pretzel though
M: I'm gonna get mine just a little, I like mine a little darker.
E: That smaller one looks really good.
M: Oh yeah, that looks like a real pretzel!
M: I feel like if anything's gonna drag me down, it'll be the fact that I didn't put mine in boiling water
E: Yeah
M: But that'll be proven by my big boy.
If my big boy comes out big good, you know that it was my problem
E: See they all, they all look pretty good.
T: They do
E: but now it's just gonna come to the taste..
M: Ooh yeah. That's what I call some pizzas!
M: These are our pretzels. They are looking pretty good. I'd say from an aesthetic perspective
Tyler is definitely taking the cake on this one. Those look great
There's only a little unevenness here but like the shape, the consistency, the, the dough itself. It looks really nice.
Yours would be a second just because they got the uniformity. the twists aren't quite good.
E: I think the- I think the toast is pretty even.
M: Yeah
T: Yeah, you got a nice toast.
M: And it looks plump, a little too plump.
E: a little too plump.
M: mine look a mess
M: i think-
T: they look like super twisty
M: Well, I- They don't look any different than they did when I took them out of the water because like just soaking there..
I think it's sogged it up a bit which is why it took a little longer..
It's not quite as crisp as I- yeah
E: but if history repeats itself the ugly one may taste the best.
T: That's true
M: It might, it might. I also destroyed it with salt because I didn't care.
You can see just a stripe of salt here. Nothing really
Uh..
consistent about this
E: Yours are pretty even so
T: This is even- even dusting
Yeah, you did..yours- yours has a touch of quality to it.
T: I will say it's a light lighter salted site appeals to my heart.
M: Mm-hmm. Yeah, but that's specific taste general overall
That's close to a true pretzel.
T: right
M: Ooo hoo
M: Woo hoo
E: Big Boy
M: Quite a soggy bottom on this one. *Tyler laughs*
M: Everything isn't looking great here except for this
E: oh no..!
so now it just looks like a pig's nose that has a cold *Tyler laughs*
E: ooohhh
M: I think this is the yolk that spilled over and it got like sulphurized. So that's no good.
But the rest of it this is pretty crisp and and  kind of nice. The middle might be a little raw
But that's my mega pretzel. Um, and also that got a better boil
And I can already tell it fluffed up better because of the boil.
Anyway, I'll put this over here, That's for dessert!
E: First glance of rippin' and open doesn't look good on the inside. I don't think that's done
M: That's flakey-
T: That's raw-
T: You know what, I'm gonna give him the benefit of the doubt and go to the more done looking side
M: Yeah.
E: It looks raw on the inside-
T: It is a little raw.
The dough itself is salty, which is surprising
M: I think yeah, I think it was just like too thick which is really where it went a little off.
There's also an odd aftertaste in it.
T: Mm-hmm
E: This one's good.
M: That's good? Okay.
Yeah only a little raw in here but..
E: That one tastes like a pretzel
T: Definitely has a little bit of a crunch on the outside
M: Mm-hmm
No soggy bottom. It's the- Something about the ingredients is off 'cause it tastes a little off
T: Yeah
M:If I got this from the store, I'd be like: "Hmm, man, their pretzels are off today" but I'd still eat it, cause I paid for it.
T: yeah
Mark: If I didn't pay for it i'm not gonna finish it...
E: Honestly...that's not bad
M & T: No!
M: No, not bad.
T: Not at all
T: Alright, it's definitely crispy on the bottom. You got a nice crisp there.
M: Mm-hmm, maybe too crisp
*Tyler Eating pretzel*
Ethan: It's a little bland
T: I don't know what it is but it's got a weird flavor. At least mine does.
M: Mmm. I think, I think what it is
M: Too much water and flour so it really diluted it out.
T: And the bottom is definitely hard
M: Yeah.
E: Mm, yeah
T: Like hard hard
M: It's burnt, mmh hmm
E: Do you wanna try the other one?
M: Sure, if you want
M: It's cooked! Which is what I like
T: It is! It's definitely, cooked through.
E: I think we have the same issue on this one, The bottom's a little-
M: Yea, probly just 'cause it's soggy
M: Sat down, really baked it hard.
M: Okay, now visually appealing this. I'm looking forward to this because it looks good. It looks cooked
M: It's a bit tough, but the toughness is good. that tastes exactly like a pretzel.
T: it does
M: that taste..
M: That IS a pretzel.
T: Honestly try the parts that are twisted because those I think ended up coming out at the exact right consistency
M:That's good
M: Honestly, this is a good pretzel. I've got no flaws with that. That's well done. It looks good. The twist is good
M: It's very consistent. The bake is good. That's good!
M: If it wasn't for this,
T:yeah, the crispy bottom
M: which I think was just cuz maybe the pan we use was wrong because we all have this
*SMACK*
That's a great pretzel
E: Pretty good, pretty good.
Mark: yeah, well done.
Mark: Amy, you wanna try this?
Amy: Yeah, I'll try one
Amy: That's not bad!
M: I actually like the crispier bits more
Amy: That's good!
Mark: This is good. That's really good.
T: I am pleasantly surprised
M: Well, done man
T: Thank you
M: I rank mine the worst, yours second.. if it was cooked better, that would be much better. and
M:  um that first place, by far.
E: yeah
M: honestly, I wonder if your fridge method was better
*shrugs*
M: Like 'cause we proved ours how we're supposed to but-
M: Like even though you didn't it's still like flaky and--
E: I'm honestly very surprised that we all got something that looks like a pretzel because none of us measured anything
M: M-HEHEH
All right. So this is a boiled version of mine.
T: I don't wanna go towards that side
M: yeah
M: It's probably not cooked in the center. I would imagine..
M: Oh no actually
E: Oh It's Okay
E: its a little underdone
T: nah its actually good
M: Surprisingly here
*snifff*
M: Smells like a pretzel.
E: Mmm, it doesn't taste good heh
T: It has an interesting...
T: It has an interesting scent to it
M: Yeah that pretzel smell that I smell that's gone now
I think it was just residual waft from yours. T: *Laughs* M: And now I'm getting like that snot. It just doesn't feel appealing
M: This is too much like bread
T: Yeah
M: I think I made bread
M: Anyway...
that is...
Pretzel!
To recap, Tyler..if that was in any store..
I would not question it in anyway. That is a good pretzel.
Yours was not bad. (in reference to Ethan's pretzel)
Um, mine was just bad.
But that's because I made bread instead and also put oil in it
I did a lot of things wrong in this one but-
T: You know what, Ethan's would have been better if you hadn't gone this THICC
E: mm..
M: Yeah maybe
E: Given the time constraint that we had though, I think we did- I think we all did pretty good
T: Yeah.
E: Cuz how long- how long is it supposed to set for or proof for?
Amy: an hour
E: An hour? We did like 15 minutes maybe
M: Yeah..
T: Mmh hmm
E:Maybe..
Mark: But, uh, thank you guys so much for joining me
And if you want to try pretzels at home
It's not THAT HARD but follow what Tyler was doing and not what we were doing-
E: Or follow a recipe
T: Yeah, like that's--
M: No
T: Probably a better idea
M: No, don't do that. That's actually stupid because i-..it
it stifles innovation and it stifles critical thinking
and it stifles independence and you want--
Like, it's like a parent, you want to let your kids run around in the woods
Like just do it. Let 'em eat dirt. Let 'em eat worms. That's what I did as a kid.
T: That's what I did too
M: and i-
M: w-we turned out great!
M: Of the three of us the most well-developed of the three of us are us two. (Mark and Tyler)
M: you can see that.
M: Obviously.
E: ..well, I..developed well..
E: ..developed..
*Mark and Tyler buffs up*
M: Yeah. Yeah sure thing. Okay
M: yeah, um, but yeah! no, this is great
M: Thank you everybody so much for watching. If you've got other ideas for "Makes" videos write them down in the comments below
M: We'll do a whole bunch more in the future and uh-
M: Check out Ethan's channel at CrankGameplays
M: or at Crankgame on youtube
M: youtube.com/crankgame
E: It- it redirects so just do CrankGameplays
M: CrankGameplays!
M: And.. uh
twitch.tv/Apocalypto_12
M: over here
T: Yup
M: Thank you guys so much and as always, we'll see you in the next one.
M: buh-bye!
T: bye!
M: bye..
M: *points at Tyler's pretzels* This is not bad
T: I'm pleasantly surprised
M: yeah..
M:
*Tyler starts dancing*
*Outro starts*